and ladies and gentlemen I tried to
bring you the best I try to bring you
the best and then dr. Joel wallets work
has resulted in the publication of more
than 70 peer review and and and referred
journal articles in the fields of
nutrition and pharmaceutical research he
promotes worldwide health beauty and
youthful energy and for more than 40
years it has been dr. Wallach smishing
to bring accurate and timely health
information to the world ladies and
gentlemen I want you to stand to your
feet and welcome our speaker for the
next couple of nights as he takes us on
a journey to achieve in the health that
we want please welcome dr. Joel Wallach
as he comes at this time this program is
meant to present nutritional information
only and is in no way meant to replace
the advice of your medical doctor and
now the superstar of alternative health
and purveyor of medical truth dr. Joel
Wallach thank you pastor dollar and
pastor Taffy and his whole crew they've
been so wonderful
ok diabetes 1/3 of Americans have
diabetes it's higher in the black
community the Hispanic community is the
least in the Asian community ok
diabetes is a simple mineral deficiency
disease it's not genetic type 2 diabetes
makes up 90% of the diabetic population
in America and say simple mineral
deficiency disease we've known this
since 1957 we've known this since 1957
there's a simple mineral deficient
disease and I take the mighty nine and I
take what we call the sweeties which is
the trace minerals necessary to support
promote I can legally say support
promote healthy carbohydrate and sugar
metabolism at the cellular level
supporting promote healthy blood sugar
levels we've already established that
micromanaging blood pressure doesn't
save you from being killed by high blood
pressure micromanaging your blood sugar
doesn't save you from being killed by
diabetes because high blood sugar is
just a symptom
of diabetes is not diabetes you have to
fix the cell walls okay
this program is meant to present
nutritional information only and is in
no way meant to replace the advice of
your medical doctor
you